bonjour je m'appelle fabien olicard j'ai
39 ans depuis huit jours en enregistre
cette vidéo le 30 novembre 2000 21 oui
je suis sur youtube depuis le 1er
janvier 2016 vous l'avez compris c'est
la dernière vidéo de l'année de 2021 et
j'ai voulu faire un truc est directement
inspirée d'un concept qui avait fait
selon je te parle sur sa chaîne à savoir
faire une vidéo pour le futur et dans le
futur regardez cette vidéo et répondre
aux questions et comparer les réponses
du passé avec les réponses d'aujourd'hui
du futur je vais pas faire ça tout seul
d'ailleurs il va ya voir loïc avec moi
et peut-être dans le futur ce sera que
lui qui répondra coup que moi uno ou
personnelles général
salue c'est loïc je suis au montage et
je viens de me rendre compte qu'il ya un
gros problème sur ma liste sont
forcément donc désolé je ne peux pas
utiliser ma piste sont utilisera la pi
ce sont 2 fabien de son micro donc je
serai un peu plus bas voilà bonne vidéo
cette vidéo elle sort donc le 30
décembre 2021 oui et on la regardera toi
et moi dans trois ans tout pile 30
décembre 2000 24,5 de 24,3 en oisans là
ça fait précisément six ans que je fais
des vidéos sur internet is en moins un
mois bah ouais et nous on a commencé à
travailler ensemble fin 2010 c'est tout
à fait ça fait quatre ans 15 t'as vu ma
barbe blanche a vu tabac on en cherche
c'est bien vrai père noël avant l'heure
et moi je t'ai vu devenir goalball c'est
très gentil oui
donc l'idée c'est que on se pose des
questions ou pas d'ailleurs on peut
aussi faire des états des lieux de
certains trucs voilà je vais t'en faire
un par exemple à j et bien voilà nous
sommes en 2021 et c'est toi qui occupe
un peu du pôle vidéo qui le manager
corsair comme ça est ce que tu te
considères comme un bon manager
aujourd'hui mieux qu'au début au début
j'ai tant sa vie tu m'énerves et avec je
retrouve mon âme de pédagogue maintenant
ça va un peu très peur de ce mois
pédagogue l'oreille c'est pas à toi je
me pose la question de comment va
évoluer youtube est ce que ce sera
encore comme c'est maintenant puisqu'on
voit maintenant et que tous les tics toc
c'est ça change faudrait être fou le
multiplateforme peut-être notre vidéo
retour dans trois ans elles durent 15
secondes sur la plateforme twitter
là nous en 2021 on vient de subir la
plus grosse perte de vue du youtube game
dans le youtube games à peu près 30% de
vues en moins pour tous les créateurs
les gros les petits et les moyens et les
cpm qui baissent les cpm c'est les
revenus youtube qui nous permettent de
financer les vidéos ce qui fait qu'on
est obligé de faire plus de partenariats
aussi plus youtube existe depuis
longtemps plus maintenant vous êtes
habitué à voir des gros concept c avant
les gros concept c'était le truc de
l'année aujourd'hui à xm sombre concept
c'est tous les lundis lundi qu'est ce
que ça donnera sa internet en gros c'est
internet dans trois ans coin mais ouais
je crois que tu as raison il faudrait
être fou le multiplateforme alors tiré
un état des lieux sur tous les réseaux @
fabian les cas on a 4 5 millions
d'abonnés tous confondus est sûre tik
tok qui a l'air d'être le plus porteur
au moment où vous parle j'ai six cent
mille abonnés peut-être dans trois ans
de 6 millions d'abonnés et je suis
devenu tic toc air à plein temps et toi
tu passes ta vie à faire des montages de
15 secondes
je pense qu'on travaillait encore
ensemble dans trois mois je pense oui vu
comme mon choix dans trois ans je récuse
j'aurai 34 ans je sais pas si je serai
encore à faire des vidéos à être monteur
de radio quotidienne comme ça parce
qu'on aurait voulu faire de tout ce
qu'on l'a vue là on a commencé à faire
un peu le docu même qu'il était très new
tube on a fait notre première fiction
est notre premier docu les deux étaient
très youtube mais c'est la première fois
qu'on fait ça en quatre ans qu'on bosse
ensemble n'ont fait combien de fiction
d'entre eux dont on bat deux
trois ans pour en faire une banque si on
aimerait plus rapide j'ai du mal à me
projeter sur les vidéos du mois suivant
donc je t'avoue que j'ai du mal à me
projeter sur dans trois ans et ça va ya
le temps trois ans et en même temps
qu'on le vit dans le quotidien tu dis ça
passe vite vite vite hein quand même
cette année là c'est trop bizarre je
sais pas vous allez passer est-ce qu'on
a repris twitch dans trois ans est-ce
qu'on refait des lives thomas et
pourquoi tu es devant moi non je rigole
mais si tu es devant moi [ __ ] qu'est
ce que tu fais là alors je pense qu'on
en a on en aura refait moi
professionnellement j'ai spectacle je
vais faire la dernière de mon spectacle
singularité le 11 décembre au zénith et
après je pars en création du nouveau à
partir de janvier est ce que je fais
encore du spectacle dans trois ans je
pense j'espère en fait j'espère au moins
faire un autre spectacle dans ma vie
1023 de musique à 2025 moi et j'espère
que je suis encore sur un nouveau
spectacle mais je pense que je ferai
moins de tournées après moi je me dis 39
+ 3g 42 mais je me projette à l'ocde 45
tu vois où je me dis est ce que j'ai
envie de partir tous les deux jours en
tournée c'est le rush quoi c'est la
galère quand on a bien vu ont battu le
voir
salut tout le monde on est mardi et bat
salut tout le monde
on se revoit mardi il y en a toujours
pour me dire bon week end jeu dbz pas
compris ce que c'est la tournée du sida
quand sa balle arrêtée là pour une riche
comme toi vie perso on habite à paris
oui l'un des studios on habite où nous
en trois ans moi je le vois encore à
paris mais pas dans un studio dans deux
studios auraient battu est idiot est-ce
que des propriétaires je ne suis pas
propriétaire et dans trois ans j'espère
l'être pour habiter ou pour l'autre pour
un investissement locatif
si je déménage en province je me suis je
te suis tu mets une petite dépendance
sur le côté comme ça c'est tout terrain
avec un emploi à un lit tout droit comme
celle qui micro à la place mallet un
bonne nuit à demain tu es heureux je
suis ravi d'être moi j'ai pas d'amis oui
plus plus je dis oui ça va plus je sais
ce que je veux et qui je suis à peu près
moi je suis heureux mais plus je
vieillis plus je me dis vraiment trois
quatre ans encore à à gaz et un peu et
retraite anticipée mais il va falloir
mettre un bon coup de froid un moment
donné et je pense que ce sera à l'issue
du prochain spectacle est ce que dans
trois ans tu dois toujours faire des
vidéos une vidéo par semaine sur youtube
non
maintenant je dis ça comme comme
utiliser là tout à l'heure les années
elles passant en boum comme ça et c'est
à dire qu'il ya six ans je me voyais pas
faire des vidéos dans six ans et j'en
fais encore tu vas en fait c'est lé
rythme que je vois différemment dans
trois ans tu vois je me vois plus faire
une vidéo par semaine faire quinze dates
de tournée par moi tu vois tout ça je le
vois moins de projets mais comme je
m'épanouis dans la diversité je me vois
continue à faire des trucs mai mais
moins de densité en fait moins de flux
dans les choses que tu vois après
peut-être dans trois ans moi j'aimerais
bien aussi commencé à peut-être produire
peut-être pas d'autres gens je suis pas
sûr que je sois que je sais que j'ai
l'âme d'un bon producteur d'un artiste
ou pas tu vois peut arriver avec un
projet de fiction et 11 i way vas-y
sherlock ce qu'on produit ou coproduit
ou un truc comme ça mais plus des
projets en fait plus produire des
projets qu'est ce que tu veux en plus
dans ta vie ou pour ta vie dans trois
ans si des trucs plus stable
émotionnellement
tf1 connaît c'est le bruit des bagnoles
bleus de tout temps il ya du bruit des
travaux et des
klaxons aussi aux feux rouges c'est
important parce que klaxons fait passer
le feu au vert beaucoup plus rapidement
et plus qu'à l'ouverture du coup
finalement est-ce que c'est pas aussi je
veux moins de bruit en moi peut-être ça
aussi ce que tu apprends à te connaître
dans cette vidéo et du coup tout va bien
alors c'est bizarre j'aimerais plus de
stabilité parce que mine de rien au
niveau pro par exemple on a l'impression
que ça marche très bien et tout et moi
je sais comment on tient tout à bout de
bras avec fanny quoi tu vois se demande
vraiment du travail énormément d'énergie
et j'aimerais que ce soit plus stable
pour qu'ils aient moins d'efforts à
faire les choses dépendent moins deux
mois ça c'est ce que je me souhaite et
si je devais retirer quelque chose
peut-être quand même être moins
contrôlant si j'étais moins contre l'aja
plus d'attendre sa cession par rapport
aux geeks un ace moyen continue tu
pendant trois ans n'a sorti 3 ouais j'ai
nommé j'ai déjà deux trois idées
d'autres livres est alors un peu comme
pour les vidéos à terme mais à terme bah
ouais j'aimerais bien passer sur de la
belle soeur de la fiction et et tu vois
de tout ce que je fais dans la vie le
seul truc que je projette assez
facilement à plus 3 + 6 + 10 plus 15 ans
c'est écrire et écrire tant que j'ai des
choses que j'ai envie d'écrire jamais en
forçant tu vois qu'est-ce qui aura le
plus changé entre maintenant et dans 3
donc pour toi qu'est-ce qui aurait le
plus changé l'économie ouais je crois
qu'il va y avoir des fossés d'inégalité
sociale encore plus forte qu'aujourd'hui
ce qui pourrait déclencher des guerres
civiles pour moi c'est l'économie tu
vois c'est et on va avoir les retombées
dans trois ans ce sera des vraies
grosses retombées de la période qu'ovide
est la période où ils ont fait marcher
la machine à billets aussi pour nous
arroser qui va servir d'argument aussi à
terme je pense aussi que l'écologie bien
sûr à bien bouger dans les choses et je
pense qu'on va arriver à la période on
va dire peut-être on va plus pouvoir
changer de téléphone non plus dans pas
si longtemps parce que ben on a pu les
métaux pour aussi tu vois il y avait
aussi la transformation technologique
qui va pas être celle je pense qu'on
avait dans les films et dans les séries
en fait ces deux trucs là me font penser
que peut-être dans trois ans il ya
peut-être eu un peu
l'exode d'inverser les gens partent des
villers autant de plus en fait sur sur
les 80 % de territoires plus campagne je
suis aussi que les sinistres quant à
changement tout ce qui est écologique je
pense que malheureusement et je
comprends aussi les gens pour l'instant
c'est trop dur de j'ai pu droit de
prendre ma voiture j'ai pu leur faire ça
si peu de temps pour se dire que révèle
un vrai show il faut être il faudrait
presque qu'on soit contraint en fait bah
c'est ça mais c'est un peu compliqué tu
comprends tu fais pas ouais mais à tout
et c'est un peu comme par exemple qui
ont dit oui il faut réduire ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et on
dit ça c'est pour toute la planète et du
coup je comprends même si je pourrai pas
le faire que des pays fassent ouais mais
attendez les gars vous vous l'avez fait
pendant chez ça revient de temps et nous
on a plus loin et comme en a eu et j'ai
peur que s'il regardait la même manière
nous on est on est rigolo à dire ça en
france est de dire la chimie pollue mais
nous on fait tous venir de chine et on a
délocalisé là bas donc j'ai bien peur
qu'on soit déjà 6e 12 en trois ans de
quoi garder leurs locaux vides du gauche
dans trois ans ça fait partie du
quotidien il aura encore le colis de nul
et sa fille de deux ans et est ce que je
vois pas toujours en 2023 loïc joly veut
dire que non parce que je sais que tu
peux te faire des terres des motifs
comme ça de j'arrête moi j'espère que
dans trois ans j'aurais arrêté je pense
que dans trois ans j'aurais arrêté bas
côté j'espère aussi moi j'espère que
dans trois ans je me serais fait opérer
des yeux mais en vrai ça tout à voir
j'espère que j'aurai arrêté de papoter
que je me serais fait opérer des yeux
puisque 1 mais but dans la vie c'est
d'être le plus autonome possible le fait
de dépendre de ma cigarette électronique
ou de dépendre de mes lunettes m'agace
profondément mais il ya des belles comme
ça pour repérer les yeux quand on n'est
vraiment pas loin de l'actualité au
laser est ce que dans trois ans est papa
non parce que denis qui travaillent avec
nous et je pense que denis sera bien
papa vous rien d'un deuxième quart et
mac j'ai l'impression qu'ils sont je
sais là je veux un enfant moi je pense
que je serai jamais prêt comme ça 2 je
sais j'ai un enfant je pense que sa
femme a compté 10 tu vas être je pense
que ce sera bon et c'est comme ça eh ben
je suis enceinte et geffré oui mais toi
pas bien fait de suivre trois ans moi
j'espère que je serai papa non j'espère
au moins avoir un enfant
moi j'ai investi hier j'ai passé un mode
non mais j'espère j'espère que j'aurai
un enfant ou n'importe lequel et après
jamais si c'est un homme ou une femme à
garçon une fille
c'est toi qui va induire en erreur
par 6 essais c'est un petit garçon et
une petite fille oui moi je voulais te
papa très jeune j'aurais kiffé ca de 20
à 25 ans jeté à l'eau je m'en fous
pourquoi bas pour chez pas pour avoir
une petite différence d'âge parce que je
voulais des enfants mon rêve dans ma vie
serait peut-être d'être père au foyer tu
vois le bar 3 4 enfants un choix avec
nous un peu papa au foyer marié marié
mais son jeu s'est posté ici donc
espérer de bons jeux rien contre le
bahreïn je me même plutôt l'idée du
mariage mais par contre je sais pas si
précisément là je suis marié ou pas ah
ouais je pense qu'on sera mieux
habillées oui c'est possible ça c'est
jour 1b tout en vient on regarde bien la
caméra là pour comme ça on pourra se
comparer je suis devenu chauve à
un niveau hostilités chaud avec une
barre comme ça je vais dire avec une
moustache et on s'appelle viktor vincent
et moi j'ai pas de style c'est ça le
truc en fait je pense que le mec dans
trois ans qui regarde cette vidéo le
loïc de vingt trois ans ce que tu penses
qu'il est fier du lohic demain devant
eux non
et du coup toi tu penses que celui de
dans trois ans tu vas en être fier là
maintenant tu penses que tu peux avoir
confiance en lui oui à celui de nos
trois ans récemment j'ai eu une des
terres il faut arrêter ben parce que
c'était vraiment ce truc c'est quand je
me suis dit à mon nez déjà la fin de
l'année j'avais dix-sept années et non
je me dis bah ouais mais trois non ça va
aller très vite donc d'une vraie des
terres de l'asie on fait des trucs que
j'ai toujours cette peur de me lancer
parce que j'avais tour ce truc ouais
mais ça se trouve je vais pas réussir et
puis ça va pas marcher donc autant pas
le faire mais du coup on fait du coup
s'il comme j'applique et ça a tout dans
la vie et ben c'était vite champ pour
tous ahmadi donc je me suis dit
j'abandonne ça parce que c'est il faut
que tu sais pas et ça marche ça marche
ça marche pas tant pis mais en comptant
un beau mec 0
mais exercer ce que c'est moi qui ai
inventé cette expression et pourrait
répondre ça moi moi toujours très
critique envers moi donc je pense que
moi dedans trois ans de juges beaucoup
c'est ma hantise moi c'est que c'est que
mon mois du futur débarque dans une
capsule temporelle qui me regardent et
qui me passe je sais moi je sais tu vas
pas me la faire et je sais tout sur toi
tu vois donc je pense que je suis très
très critique sur moi dans trois ans et
d'ailleurs je suis critique sur le fait
que je veux dire cette phrase là déjà
c'est sur quoi je pense que je moi je
serai fier du mois de dans trois ans que
si pour le coup il est papa épanouie qui
est qui gère bien sa vie de famille et
si tous - du futur y débarquent ils
essaient de trouver une pnc gratuit tu
pars tu veux dire que c'est comme ça bah
non
et toi oui je vous dit peut-être une
raison c'est pour sauver un truc dans le
futur moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est poser
cette question tu veux te taper chose de
triage
tu veux te pouillard ce que moi le mois
du futur je me suis je me suis jamais
dit qu'il pouvait arriver pour rouler
une pelle que je sais que ça n'arrivera
jamais je pense qu'on peut arrêter là
vous savez mais mettez dans les
commentaires répondait un peu aux
questions auxquelles on a répondu à ce
que vous rouler une pelle à votre goût
du futur os est ce que vous pensez que
votre vous du futur vous jugerez bien
mal mais mettez ça en fait l'espace
commentaires comme si c'était une petite
capsule temporelle puis on re découvre
ça tous ensemble en décembre 2024 faut
que je mette un rappel dans l'agenda
peut-être que en 2002 24 ans fera 308
par vidéo
c'est ça aussi c'est la guerre du temps
de l'attention bah merci à celles et
ceux qui ont regardé en entier qu'on
encore assez de temps d'attention pour
regarder des vidéos entière cole sont
fait un peu à l'ancienne comme ça
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner qu'on passe
les deux millions d'abonnés avant 2024
peut-être et rejoignez-nous sur tik tok
l'eau simon tic toc prenez soin de vous
excellente fête de fin d'année ils sont
passés dans les passes et passer un bon
jour de l'an et on se revoit le 3
janvier à 18h sur youtube ça va parler
de mentalist va ça va faire du
mentalisme et on va même parler de
nostradamus
des dislike dans tout ça sera disparu le
monde serait ce au débit des sources on
sera tous dans le métavers ce absolument
j'en peux plus de ce mot